ja willkommen zur virtuellen
ersatzsitzung zur Auswahlsitzung
Grundbegriffe der praktischen
Philosophie wie immer möchte ich zu
Beginn des begriffsnetz vorstellen und
an manchen Stellen erweitern anknüpfend
weitere Begriffe eingeben
wir haben zunächst immer die Person oder
das menschliche tier ist immer die Frage
kann man schon diskutieren aber davon
geht ab die individuelle Person die
kollektive Person falls sie sowas
überhaupt gibt die Handlung individuell
oder Kollektiv
dann kann man die Handlung unterscheiden
komplexe Handlung oder in
basishandlungen
man kann zwischen äußeren Handlungen das
sind Handlungen wo wir uns bewegen im
Raum wo wir unsere Hände bewegen also
äußere Handlungen innere Handlungen
unterscheiden innere Handlung sind
Handlung in denen wir uns nicht bewegen
im Raum wo sie sich bewegen müssen wo
wir
allein mentale Operationen vollziehen
können auch das kann man als Handlung
ansehen nur treten die nicht aus unserem
Kopf heraus und man sieht uns gar nicht
an dass wir handeln vielleicht sieht man
an da ist jemand jetzt ganz konzentriert
auch den Willensbildungsprozess könnte
man als eine solche innere Handlung
ansehen auf den da noch eine äußere
Handlung folgt ne und dann haben wir
noch diskutiert kürzlich das Thema
sprachhandlung da mache ich oben rechts
den Link rein
sprachhandlung sind auch Handlung die
auf eine ganz eigentümliche Weise
vollzogen werden nämlich indem wir
einfach einen Willen bekommen
ja ich will man muss natürlich bestimmte
Kontexte voraussetzen und wenn wir das
sagen ja ich will dann sagen wir nicht
dass wir etwas wollen sondern wir tun
etwas nämlich wir gehen eine Ehe ein
durch diese sprachhandlung kann man auch
noch andere
Phänomene damit bezeichnen etwa den Satz
ich vermache meine Uhr meiner Tochter
Anne zum Beispiel von Austin den wir da
herangezogen haben der Buch geschrieben
hat how to do things with words also man
kann auch mit geschriebener Sprache
handeln das nennt
Austin performative
Sprechakte also sprich Akte die nicht
nur beschreiben sondern etwas vollziehen
dann haben wir den Willen untersucht vom
Wunsch abgegrenzt der Wille ist ein
handlungswirksamer Wunsch wünschen kann
ich mir vieles aber wollen dann muss ich
alle Schritte ergreifen um sie zu einer
Handlung zu führen wir haben eine
gewisse Grund des diskutiert der im
Gegensatz zum Begriff der Willkür steht
willkürliche Handlung sind Handlung die
nicht begründet sind sondern Vernunft
haben wir Instrument Telefon Vernunft
dann die kategorischen Imperativ als
moralische Vernunft und das hatte David
jung gerade bestritten damit will ich
sagen Immanuel kannst Theorie ist nicht
unangefochten
Vernunft im Handeln steht dem Phänomen
wo wir wieder besseres Wissen Handeln
obwohl wir wissen dass alle guten Gründe
für Handlungen sprechen Handlung ist
Option ah sprechen tun wir B
sie in den Auges wie kann man das
erklären
Selbsttäuschung werden wir noch genauer
behandeln auch interessantes Phänomen
wir haben die ganze freiheitsdebatte
aufgerollt in ihren Grundzügen positive
Freiheit heißt Freiheit zu etwas
negative Freiheit von etwas
positive Freiheit kann man
Handlungsfreiheit unter verstehen tun
können was man will oder Willensfreiheit
wollen können was man will oder seinen
eigenen Willen bilden können das
natürlich auch irgendwie eine Handlung
in der Willensfreiheit ganz eng damit
zusammenhängt der Begriff der Autonomie
den Immanuel kann natürlich vor allem
verwendet dann müssen wir die drei
Phänomene oder Modalitäten
determination Notwendigkeit Indifferenz
immer mit der Freiheit Beziehung setzen
genau genommen mit der Willensfreiheit
und dann ergibt sich zwei Positionen
kompatibilismus also der termination und
Willensfreiheit sind kompatibel die sind
beide wahr sein und wir können dir noch
frei sein und dagegen steht der
inkompatibilismus entweder Determinismus
oder Willensfreiheit sind falsch und je
nachdem was man sagt kommt einmal der
harte der terminismus raus wenn man sagt
der terminismus ist wahr auf Kosten der
Willens Freitag ist ein harte der Termin
ist wenn man sagt der terminismus ist
falsch zugunsten der willensfrei dann
ist man eine libertarianerin aber da
muss man allerdings sowas wie
Indifferenz annehmen
unentschiedene terminierte Zustände die
nicht durch die Naturgesetze der
terminiert sind und dann wird es wieder
schwierig in Differenz mit
Willensfreiheit zu vereinbaren wohin man
schaut es gibt immer Probleme er hat die
Philosophie seid ja hunderten wenn ich
da seit Jahrtausende noch keine absolut
gültige Antwort gefunden und wird das
wahrscheinlich auch nicht tun dennoch
kann man gute Gründe für die eine oder
andere Position anführen jetzt möchte
ich noch einen weiteren Bereich ergänzen
unsere Begriff selbst nehme ich den
Bereich rund um die Emotionen mit denen
wir es in den letzten Sitzung zu tun
hatten wir haben uns damit der Liebe vor
allem befasst nach Frankfurt und die
Liebe bringt er mit dem Grund in eine
Beziehung das ist ganz interessant
normalerweise denkt man doch liebe hat
doch mit Grund und vernünftig zu tun
nicht so sagt Harry fremd wird liebe ist
die Quelle der Gründe Quelle von Gründen
also sie kann unser Handeln motivieren
rechtfertigen stützen wir wollen noch
eine andere Emotionen heute diskutieren
nämlich die Achtung die moralische
Achtung und die steht nach Kant in einem
ganz eng Verhältnis zum kategorischen
Partizip sie ist ein Ausdruck desselben
ja so viel so ein bisherigen Begriff
Netz wir gehen weiter und machen
Rückblick auf die letzte Sitzungen wie
viel unterscheiden sich Emotionen von
Gefühlen das haben wir da uns überlegt
wir haben uns auch noch mal überlegt
inwiefern Emotionen rational sind und
Gründe und das Handelns können sie
Emotionen zum Handel verlieren was sind
moralische Gefühle darum soll es heute
gehen
was ist eine Emotion ich habe hier ein
ganzes ganze Liste von möglichen
Emotionen gebracht muss gleich dazu
sagen wie die freiheitsdebatte so ist
auch die Moral und Emotion Debatte sehr
umstritten man muss gute Gründe angeben
warum sich jetzt dabei wirklich um eine
Emotion handelt man muss auch erstmal
erklären was Emotion ist
Mitleid steht im Zentrum bei David jung
und hatte Schopenhauer wir kommen heute
drauf achtung bei Kant hatten wir schon
Scham ist eine Emotion Ekel Verzweiflung
Angst leitet Eifersucht Liebe Sattel
Frankfurt bei der Angst muss man
natürlich noch sagen Angst könnte man
einfach auch als Angstgefühle oder als
ja vielleicht sogar perfekt ansehen
natürlich ist das immer eine ganz
spezielle Prägung von Angst eine ganz
spezielles
Verständnis von Angst das ist gar nicht
die Angst die wir gewöhnlich kennen man
muss aber die Angst natürlich auch
unterscheiden von der Furcht wir
fürchten uns vor etwas wir haben einen
klares Bewusstsein vor die von
demjenigen wovor wir uns fürchten bei
der Angst ist es gar nicht so klar wovor
man sich
ängstet ängstigt also Angst ist er
häufig die Welt Angst als eine
Orientierungslosigkeit und das ist
natürlich ein fast schon philosophisches
Gefühl nach Martin heiliger ja wie
können wir jetzt Emotionen von Affekten
Gefühlen und Stimmung unterscheiden
Affekte vollziehen sich sehr schnell und
intensiv so dass wir bei Handlungen im
Affekt nicht viel reflektieren und
vorstell Handeln Affekte sind deswegen
keine guten Gründe für Handlungen
man tut manche Dinge im Affekt und
bereut sie hinterher man wird wenn er
sich dabei unmoralische Dinge handelt
häufig auch nicht ganz zurechenbar
verurteilt
weil man nicht Herr seiner selbst ganz
aber warum weil man nicht reflektieren
konnte weil da etwas in einem sich
geregt hat ein übermannt hat der Effekt
man nicht genug in kontrollieren konnte
das heißt
Emotionen werden sich als etwas
herausstellen was Kontrolle gerade noch
erlaubt
Affekte scheint damit mit Rationalität
in einem Widerspruch zu stehen
Stimmungen dagegen die halten an
Gegensatz zum affektstimmungen haben
eine Ausdehnung ich kann längere Zeit in
einer bestimmten Stimmung sein und sie
legen sich ein Schleier über uns also
sie motivieren uns nicht so sehr wie es
Affekte tun sie drücken uns und Zustand
gar nicht so aus wenn Sie
legen etwas über uns sie färben die Welt
ein wie eine Linse einer bestimmten
Farbe aber sie drücken nicht so sehr
unsere innere Energie aus Stimmungen
sind häufig nichts sonderlich
Energietisch ist man spricht zwar in der
Psychologie manchmal von affektiven
Störungen aber das sind eigentlich
stimmungsstörungen keine Effekte
Gefühle muss man davon noch
unterscheiden Gefühle die ich jetzt mal
zum Beispiel am Beispiel des Schmerzes
des Hungers diskutiere Gefühle sind ihr
äußerlich und sie dauern auch nicht so
lange an auf die Stimmungen deswegen
sind Gefühle in meinen Augen keine
möglichen Gründe Verhandlungen
und jetzt kommt aber im Unterschied dazu
die emotionenzentrum Emotionen drücken
unsere Subjektivität aus sie nehmen uns
ganz im Beschlag und sie erlauben
zugleich und zwar im Gegensatz zu
Affekten die Reflexion deswegen eignen
sich Emotionen als Gründe und Motive für
unser Handeln so verstehe ich jetzt
Emotionen als etwas was unser Innerstes
ausdrückt und nicht nur eine
Äußerlichkeit und zum Hunger also unsere
Magen ausdrückt oder irgendwie eine
Wunde ausdrückt sondern Emotionen
drücken unser Innerstes unser
eigentliches ich aus
vielleicht machen das auch Affekte aber
im Unterschied zu Affekten sind
Emotionen ausgedehnt und nicht nur
punktuell das heißt sie erlauben
Reflexion und Kontrolle deswegen sind
wir ganz bei uns selbst wenn wir in
Emotionen Handeln zum Beispiel aus Liebe
zu einer anderen Person handeln da sind
wir zwar emotional sehr eingenommen aber
nicht so wie im Affekt fast schon
unbeherrscht
wir können das ganze kontrollieren und
deswegen kann man auch sagen wer aus
Emotionen handelt handelt aus Freiheit
weil man da sein ich ausdrückt auf eine
reflektierte Weise denken Sie an Harry
Frank wird betrifft der Identifikation
mit unseren Wünschen und man neigt dazu
wie Harry Frank wird etwas Liebe mit
Autonomie also mit individueller
Gesetzgebung Selbstbestimmung deine enge
Verwandtschaft Beziehung zu setzen wir
werden darauf gleich noch näher eingehen
das halte ich eine wichtige
Unterscheidung wie hängen jetzt
Emotionen mit unserem Handeln zusammen
ich hatte schon Harry friend wird wieder
erwähnt er hat ein Buch geschrieben
und love ein weiteres Buch the reasons
of Love auf Deutsch Gründe der Liebe und
daraus lesen
er sagt some loving someone aus
something centrally means or consist in
Amon other things taking it's interest
as reasons for acting to serve those
interest jetzt kommt der wichtiger Satz
love is
itself for the Lover source of reasons
it creates the reasons by which his acts
of loving concern and die Motion
is acts of loving concern in Devotion
are inspired also es geht dabei um
Gründe
die
unser Handeln motivieren und recht
werden
weiteres Zitat
one disting the feature of loving has to
the particulos Tattoos of the value that
is a
qualitys in so far as we care about
something it all we we got it is
importants only because we got it is to
something else when we love something
about
it
Notdienst
in the nature loving that we considers
to be well you will in the cells and
trust
wenn wir etwas lieben dann
sprechen wir diesem geliebten Wesen
einer Person in der Regel einen Wert zu
der aber in sich selbst besteht als ein
Selbstzweck und nicht nur ein Mittel zum
Zweck das ganz interessant ich werde
gleich näher darauf eingehen dieses
Struktur sich auf etwas anderes
emotional zu beziehen so dass wir ihm
einen Eigenwert ein absoluten Wert zu
sprechen ist ganz eng verbunden mit ganz
Forderung des kategorischen Imperativ
handle so dass du die andere Person
nicht nur als Mittel zum zweckseln immer
auch als selbstwert
verstehst
das heißt nachher wie Frankfurt ist
Liebe eine Quelle für Gründe unseres
Handelns damit steht die Liebe in
unserer Vernunft nicht Entgegnung obwohl
sie eine Emotion ist als Emotionen
Vernunft müssen sich nicht widersprechen
Liebe besitzt eine Ähnlichkeit zu kanns
kategorischen Imperativ da sie fordert
eine andere Person als Selbstzweck zu
behandeln das ist ganz interessant also
liebe ist eigentlich eine Form von
Autonomie nach Harry Potter das würde
natürlich kann gerade beschreiten er hat
einen anderen liebesbegriff und darauf
geben auch dieser Sitzung noch näher ein
heute soll es jetzt um moralische
Gefühle und Emotionen gehen worin
unterscheiden sich moralische Gefühle
beziehungsweise Emotionen von
moralischen das ist eine Frage wir
werden uns mit dem Mitleid mit Achtung
Liebe und auch die Neid befassen als
einen besonders unmoralischen Gefühl
oder vielleicht genauer eine
unmoralische Emotion zunächst zum
Mitleid sie kennen alle diesen
Philosophen des
artischockenauer hat die These vertreten
das Mitleid die Emotion ist die uns
allein moralisch motivieren kann oder
nein die moralische Emotion ist uns
daneben gar keine wirklich anderen
moralischen Emotionen geben kann sagt
nichts empört so im tiefsten Grunde
unserer moralisches Gefühl wie
Grausamkeit jedes andere Verbrechen
können wir verzeihen nur Grausamkeit
nicht der Grund hier von ist das
Grausamkeit das gerade Gegenteil des
Mitleids ist
grenzenloses Mitleid mit allen lebenden
Wesen sagt Schopenhauer weiter ist der
festste und sicherste Bürger für das
sittliche Wohlverhalten und bedarf
keiner Kasuistik wer davon erfüllt ist
wird zuverlässig keinen verletzten
keinen beeinträchtigen keinem weh tun
viel mehr mit jedem Nachsicht haben
jedem verzeihen jedem helfen so viel er
mag und alle seine Handlung werden das
Gepräge der Gerechtigkeit und Menschen
liebe tragen hingegen versuchen man
einmal zu sagen dieser Mensch ist
tugendhaft aber er kennt kein Mitleid
oder es ist ein ungerechte und boshafter
Mensch doch ist er sehr mitleidung so
wird er Widerspruch fühlbar also Mitleid
ist noch Schopenhauer eine Emotion die
ihn drin sich gut ist und drehen sich
moralisch gut ist die sich gar nicht mit
unmoralischen Verhalten verträgt
begrifflich schon
ja wie in der Philosophie üblich gab es
dazu natürlich eine entgegengesetzte
Position von niemand gerem als immer
manuell könnt und der schreibt hier
folgendes Neigung ist blind und Knecht
ist sie mag nun gutartig sein oder nicht
und die Vernunft wo es auf Sittlichkeit
ankommt muss nicht bloß den Vormund
derselben vorstellen sondern auf ohne
auf sie Rücksicht zu nehmen als reine
praktische Verlust ihr eigenes Interesse
ganz alleine besorgen selbst dieses
Gefühl des Mitleids und der
weichherzigen Teilnehmer wenn es vor der
Überlegung was Pflichtteil vorhergeht
und Bestimmungsgrund wird ist wohl
denken Personen selbst lästig bringt
ihre überlegte Maximen in Verwirrung
unbewirkt den Wunsch ihrer entledigt und
allein der gesetzgebenden Vernunft
unterworfen sein das ist jetzt ein
langes Zitat er will damit nur sagen
Mitleid ist nach Kant kein moralisches
Gefühl im Gegensatz zu Schopenhauer
sondern eine Neigung also etwas bloß
äußerliches heteronomes könnte man sagen
und selbst das Mitleid als weichherzige
Teilnehmer also Anteilnahme an anderen
Menschen
muss immer in Grenzen gesetzt werden
weil es sich mit der Vernunft nicht
verträgt es muss immer erst der
vernünftigen Überlegung nachfolgen ist
darf er nicht vorhergehen warum weil wir
sonst keine Kontrolle über unsere
handeln haben Mitleid ist nach
kann kein geeigneter handlungsgrund für
autonome Willensbestimmung nach
Schopenhauer ist es hingegen der einzig
da sehen sie wieder wie man sich in der
Philosophie über das selbe Thema sehr
schnell mit guten Gründen uneinig sein
kann ja kant hat natürlich was zur Liebe
auch noch gesagt
im Gegensatz jetzt zu Harry fremd wird
es ist sehr schön aus Liebe zu Menschen
und teilnehmenden wollen ihnen Gutes zu
tun oder aus Liebe Zuordnung gerecht zu
sein aber das ist noch nicht die echte
moralischen Maxime unseres Verhaltens
die uns im Standpunkte unter
vernünftigen Wesen als Menschen
angemessen ist wenn wir uns anmaßend
gleichsam als Volontäre das heißt
freiwillig uns mit stolze Einbildung
über den Gedanken von Pflicht
hinwegzusetzen und als zum Gebote
nämlich dem kategorischen Imperativ
unabhängig loser aus eigener Lust das
tun wollen wozu für uns kein Gebot not
nötig wäre
er sagt also wir sollten nicht glauben
dass wir ohne moralische Gebote handeln
sollten
moralisches Handeln setzt immer die
Pflicht den kategorischen Imperativ
voraus und Liebe verträgt sich damit
nicht sagt er ja das kann natürlich
wieder diskutieren jetzt kommt aber ein
moralisches Gefühl ich würde sagen es
ist Emotion die verkannt das einzige
echte moralisch Gefühl ist nämlich das
Gefühl der Achtung die unmittelbare
Bestimmung des Willens durchs Gesetz
dass sie im Gesetz und das Bewusstsein
derselben heißt Achtung so dass diese
als Wirkung des Gesetzes auf Subjekt und
nicht als Ursache desselben angesehen
wird eigentlich ist achtung die
Vorstellung von einem Werte der meiner
Selbstliebe tut also ist es etwas was
weder als Gegenstand der Neigung noch
der Furcht betrachtet wird obgleich ist
mit beiden zugleich etwas analogisches
hat der Gegenstände Achtung ist also
lediglich das Gesetz und zwar dasjenige
dass wir uns selbst und doch als an sich
notwendig auferlegen als Gesetz sind wir
im unterworfen ohne die Selbstliebe zu
befragen als uns von uns selbst
auferlegt ist es doch eine Folge unseres
Willens und hat in der ersten Rücksicht
Analogie mit Furcht in der zweiten mit
Neigung also Achtung ist so ein
zwischengefühl es hat eine gewisse Nähe
mit der Furcht weil wir uns natürlich
ehrfürchtig nach kann zum moralischen
Gesetz verhalten müssen und es hat auch
was zu Neigung
weil wir dahin letztendlich die höheren
Sinn unsere Existenz erkennen also in
der Achtung so kann drücken wir unser
Innerstes ganz angemessen aus nämlich
unser moralisches Wesen und nicht nur
unsere empirische Natur wie es mir nach
Kant durch die Liebe und durch das
Mitleid tun
ja
jetzt möchte ich noch zum Schluss auf
eine unmoralische Emotion eingehen und
dann habe ich mir den Neid herausgesucht
auch dazu möchte ich ein Zitat von Kant
geben er bestimmt den Neid als Hang das
Wohl anderer mit Schmerz wahrzunehmen ob
zwar den seiligen dadurch kein Abbruch
geschieht also wir sind dann neidisch
oder vielleicht genau gesagt missgünstig
wenn wir am Erfolg oder am wohl am Glück
anderer Person Leiden das ist ja erstmal
sehr rational warum sollten wir denn
leiden oder
unwohl uns fühlen wenn andere Person
Glück haben aber was ist denn da
dasselbe was ist denn da das spannende
daran obwohl uns doch selbst dadurch
nichts passiert wenn es der anderen
Person gut geht muss es uns ja nicht
schlecht gehen
bestimmt den Neid als Unwille unser
Eigenwohl durch das Wohl anderer in
Schatten gestellt zu sehen weil wir den
Maßstab desselben nicht in dessen
inneren Werte nur in der Vergleichung
mit dem Wohl anderer zu sehen zu
schätzen und diese Schätzung zu
verinnlichen wissen
also
wir sehen unser eigenes Wohl in den
Schatten gestellt durch das wohl andere
weil wir den Maßstab unseres Wohls nicht
in einem inneren Wert begründen eine
moralischen Wert sondern nur relativ mit
Blick auf das wohl antragen geht es uns
besser als den anderen dann geht es uns
gut geht es in anderen besser als uns
dann geht's uns schlecht das ist aber
nach Kant kein
objektiver Begriff des Guten und
deswegen ist auch der nahezu
problematisch
nachdem wir uns jetzt noch mal allgemein
mit Emotionen befasst haben möchten wir
ja möchte ich ihn Ausblick geben in der
nächsten Sitzung werden wir uns mit
moralischen Motivation befassen also mit
der Frage was uns zum Handeln antreibt
was ein Motiv ein Beweggrund verhandeln
sein kann natürlich kommen ja auch
wieder die Emotionen ins Spiel und jetzt
muss man sich fragen welche Emotionen
wir haben einige kennengelernt Liebe
Achtung Mitleid
eignet sich am besten dazu uns moralisch
zu motivieren das sind die Möglichkeiten
vielleicht gibt sogar noch andere die
man sich dazu denken könnte darüber
wollen wir in den nächsten Sitzung
diskutieren vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis bald